madame monsieur bonsoir soyez les
bienvenus sur ce plateau dans un nouveau
cadre et dans un nouveau décor dans
l'actualité de ce lundi un retour de
vacances se charger pour le juge
d'instruction jean louis bruguière qui a
entendu pour la première fois
aujourd'hui carlos l'ouverture au caire
de la conférence mondiale sur la
démographie avec des mesures de sécurité
exceptionnelles
la rentrée des classes à quatre jours de
la date officielle nous commencerons la
veillée d'armes dans une petite ville de
charente maritime
et puis notre invité ce soir jacques
chirac le président du rpr bonsoir après
un week end chargé en déclarations
politiques avant votre voyage pour les
dom-tom nous évoquerons vos projets les
projets que vous souhaitez développer
pour la france dans les années qui
viennent